awesome all right well there's already
a bunch of people out there on the
inter-tubes
uh to witness this uh once in a lifetime
maybe
maybe maybe it'll happen again next time
there's some amazing announcement
amazing discovery but i'm joined today
by sean m carroll of the
california institute of technology which
i believe is a small technical college
in l.a is that right
it is yeah it's you know for vocational
students who want to learn a trade
that's right well there's no better
place to learn a trade i suppose
let me close up all these windows here
and uh you're reading me loud and clear
i hope
i can hear you sound good great so
hopefully people out there are watching
and it is a treat to welcome none other
than sean carroll
uh professor dr sean carroll of the
california institute of technology
who has been a great influence on me and
many other
scientists throughout the years and one
of the things that he is best known for
in the outside of scientific
communication as many books
is that he is one of the originators of
a
modification to none other than the
maxwell's equations of electromagnetism
uh that i find uh quite quite intriguing
and it's something that
i thought of no one better to speak to
than than
sean about this claimed potential
evidence for
possible discovery of what is known as
cosmic birefringence which would be
sort of a mysterious uh discovery if
confirmed let me make sure that sean is
being shown yes he is
and here i am i'm brian keating you know
what i look like
but but it's pleasure to bring you this
live today stream and there's a lot of
people in the chat room already asking
questions i encourage you to ask
questions in the chat and we'll try to
get to them
uh and sean is joining us from his
laboratory
you know when i came to visit you last
time you only had richard feynman's desk
how did you get this
a resplendent laboratory sean you
thought i was a theorist but
no no no this is uh you know i have my
secret experiments i don't want to tell
anyone any of the details you know the
world isn't quite
ready for them yet it's another talent
that sean has that
only now are we privy to so sean i put
together some slides
which people can access if they go to my
website
under blog so i'll put that in the chat
room right now
people can go there and get um show
notes just look for the
sean carroll episode that is listed
there
i run uh a website which features uh
links to many interviews including ones
like this which you can find i'll put
this
also in the chat room on the uh
on the actual internet on the actual
youtube video
make that a public comment uh so here
in the chat you'll find the link to the
powerpoint
under i believe it's under um
bullet point number seven i'll give
people a chance to do that but i'm going
to be sharing the screen
so you don't necessarily even need the
powerpoint to follow along
but i thought it'd be fun for us to talk
over something while we're
discussing this monumental discovery
potential discovery i should say
and we'll couch that in the appropriate
gravitas as we go on
so here is the uh as a slide i'm going
to start off with a history behind this
how i
came to set this meeting up with sean
and that was because i saw an abstract
for a paper entitled
uh limits on new extraction
of cosmic birefringence from the planck
2018
polarization data and this may not sound
as uh stupendously important
and full of intrigue as both sean and i
found it
but the key sentence is shown here where
it says that this beta which we'll talk
about what that means
is a number is an angle uh that they
uh the authors uh murray
discovered had a value which is
inconsistent with zero
so it says beta equals 0 is excluded at
99.2
confidence limit that's what cl stands
for so they've
increased the precision on this and
they've
improved the accuracy too and maybe
we'll talk about the distinction between
those two
now today if you go to this link you can
download the powerpoint the links are
all clickable
if you click on this link you'll find uh
abstract not found which is kind of uh
kind of unusual for such a thing to
happen i'm not sure
what it means or why that took why that
did take place but
but nevertheless it is no longer
available so you'll have to take my word
for it i can
actually i do have a screenshot of the
original abstract which is saved for
posterity i can
share that later on if people are
interested uh but really this made me
want to talk to sean because it is
the anniversary of something very
important to us so on the third slide
i've got a picture that shows uh galileo
on the left
and also wishing a happy 30th birthday
to uh to carol field and jack eve i
think that's how you say it right sean
jackeev
and this is on a paper that shawn wrote
while he was at the harvard smithsonian
center for astrophysics
is that that's where you got your phd
right you were that's right this was my
first ever
referee publication and it is enjoying
its 30th anniversary and not only that
it is enjoying
a bountiful harvest of the currency
in which scientists like sean and myself
traffic which is citations
how many citations does this now have
you you received over a thousand i don't
know exactly how many it has as of today
i really have no idea but it is over a
thousand i only know it's over a
thousand because
um inspired tweets out when a paper gets
over a thousand citations so i i hadn't
been keeping track until then i think
behind i don't know if that's true
because behind you in the line i see a
hit counter a citation counter
in the laboratory it's real time
updating wow that's amazing
uh good i gotta get one of those for my
you know 100 citations that i have
um so getting back to the paper the
interesting thing that
that to me i can't notice the date uh
without thinking about galileo
because you published this on galileo's
426th anniversary
and that's very fitting because galileo
was one of the first people to talk
about the concept of relativity i
believe he might have been the first
right sean
uh we certainly attribute it to him i'm
always a little
careful when we talk about historical
things because my knowledge of history
is not exactly very good and
physicists certainly don't worry too
much about getting the history right
sometimes
that's right but as you encourage me
when i was writing
my book losing the nobel prize we'll get
a picture of that dairy gourd so i've
a raid here you can't see this shawn but
on on my couch
in my office i have four books that
you've provided your encomium for
including my book losing the nobel prize
uh leonard milad knows your colleague up
at caltech stephen hawking's memoir of
uh friendship and physics and the cosmic
revolutionaries handbook
uh these are books that i'm reading for
uh upcoming podcasts
so uh sean is prolific at writing his
own books writing scientific papers
and also writing blurbs which is just
he's a quadruple threat or triple threat
whatever we got up to
but getting back to this paper when this
paper came out
uh it's kind of been a slow boil i i
actually do have a list of kind of
how often these things have been cited
but i want to take us through
the title so it's not as attractive
a title as something deeply hidden or
the big picture
how'd you come up with the title i
always judge papers first and foremost
by their title and their abstract
like i said you know this is my first
ever published referee publication so i
was not
the intellectual leader really of this
effort i did a lot of uh you know
graduate student grunt work and i did my
best to provide
the ideas that i could it the title
might have been mine like
i do often uh uh become the person who
ends up with the titles
but you know this this paper itself
uh there's a long version of short
version i'll tell you the short version
of how this paper came to be
because i was a new grad student at
harvard in the astronomy department
i'm not an astronomer no one thinks i'm
an astronomer like what was i doing in
the astronomy department well the answer
is the physics department didn't let me
in
and the astronomy department did and so
george field was randomly assigned to me
as an advisor
and george was a world famous theorist
of the interstellar and intergalactic
medium so something i
literally no interest in at all but he
had sort of spent a lot a long time as
the founding director of the harvard
smithsonian center for astrophysics
and then he uh left that position and
sort of was intellectually curious
looking for new things to do
so he got into particle physics and
field theory and he actually
attended a summer school as a student
you know at age 60 something you know he
attended as a as a
young particle physicist and roman
shakib was there giving lectures and
roman at the time was very interested in
electromagnetism in three dimensions
that's three dimensions of space right
two dimensions of space
sorry three dimensions of space time so
two dimensions of space one dimension of
time
and he gave these lectures on them and
that that is the context in which this
idea of turn simon's theory
arises uh named in part after our buddy
uh jim simons
and george bless his heart you know as
the down-to-earth astrophysicist
he's like well okay but what about
four-dimensional space-time like what
about where we live like we don't live
in three-dimensional space time what is
the point of all that
and roman was like well you can't you
can't do it
in four-dimensional space-time it would
violate lorenzen variants
so george's answer was you know okay
let's do that
and that's when they brought me in and
we looked for you know if we were to do
this
and the reason why this paper has so
many citations is because
at the time in 1989 1990
the idea of violating the rents and
variants was just anathema like we knew
that lorenzo variance was right
uh so what's the point but that's not a
very scientific attitude you know a good
scientist will say well if it's not
right
how would we know and this particular
idea that we came up with was sort of
the
easiest and best way for lorenz and
variants to be wrong
there's some vector field that picks out
a preferred reference frame in
space-time
and it's gauge invariant but it's also
detectable
experimentally and so that's what we
said you know we said look
if the rents and variants were not true
here is a benign innocent way to violate
it
and here's how you would look for it
here are the experimental tests you can
do
and so what let's take us through it and
maybe take a step back what does it mean
to be
gauge invariant what does it mean to be
lorenz invariant
what do those terms mean for those of us
who may not be as expertly conversant
no exactly so modern physics uh relies
very heavily on the idea of symmetries
right and as symmetry sounds like a big
sophisticated mathematical concept
all it means is there's something you
can do
some transformation you can make some
change of perspective
that doesn't change the underlying
physical phenomena so
the most obvious thing is if i measure
you know the strength of gravity right
here
and i walk over 10 paces to the left i
measure the strength
of gravity i'm going to get the same
number right i measured the charge of
the electron it's going to be the same
number so that's
invariance under translations through
space it doesn't matter where you do
your experiment and that's an example of
a symmetry gauge invariance is another
example of a symmetry that is specific
to electromagnetism
it later got promoted to other nuclear
forces the strong nuclear force the weak
nuclear force even gravity has a kind of
gaussian variance
and it's more subtle than spatial
translations because it's completely
internal symmetry it doesn't move you
through space
it just takes the fields in your theory
the electromagnetic field the electron
the proton whatever
and changes them amongst themselves in a
certain way
and it sounds all like i said very
abstract and mathy but
it's absolutely at the heart of modern
physics all these different symmetries
highly constrain what you can do
in terms of the laws of physics what
theories you can write down what
experiments you can do
so if anything gauge invariance which is
at the heart of electromagnetism and so
forth
is more sacred than lorenzen variants
lorenzen variance is like you said
an outgrowth sort of uh leveling up of
galileo's idea
galileo said it doesn't matter where you
are and also it doesn't matter how fast
you're moving
right if you're on a train and doing an
experiment you're going to get the same
answer
the rents and variance is just the
relativity version of that
you know einstein and lorenz and
fitzgerald and point grey people like
that 100 and some years ago
said it doesn't matter where you are and
it doesn't matter how fast you're moving
but the way in which it matters is more
complicated than you thought so that's
little ransom variance
and when you speak about lagrangian i
don't want to get too detailed but
uh we talk about lagrangians that's sort
of the the
underlying generator of all things of
interest to physicists is it not
that's right when what the what you do
as a working theoretical physicist these
days
is you either invent or find
the predictions of different theories
right usually different quantum field
theories but maybe
string theory or maybe some discrete
theory maybe different kinds of theories
so what does that mean you have a theory
oh it means you have some stuff
some fields some particles whatever and
you also have some equations of motion
you have some
uh mathematical way of talking about how
that stuff
changes over time and that's what the
lagrangian gives you lagrangian is just
a slick mathematical tool
for generating the equations of motion
for your stuff
so you say when you propose a theory
here's the stuff here's a lagrangian
any first year graduate student can now
go ahead and get all the equations of
motion
i say that because i was a first-year
graduate student when i did that with
you know with these equations but
it's that's that's the everyday life of
a theoretical physicist these days
writing down legrand genes and coming up
with their consequences and was george
did he end up being your phd advisor he
did yes i worked also with people from
mit
uh alan guth and eddie fari but george
and i wrote several papers together we
are still collaborating today
30 years later wow so many people uh
talk to
uh think that uh uh ss chern was jim
simon's phd advisor but they
they actually uh if they had been if it
had been the case it wasn't uh jim
simon's had a different advisor at
berkeley
he came to berkeley to work with chern
as a graduate student but when he showed
up he found out chern was on
sabbatical for a year and he had a
different advisor but as he talked about
in my podcast with him a few months ago
with jim simons he said basically if if
he had shown up he might not have ever
created chern simon's theory
because he would have been just this
rube of a grad student
and by the time he was actually working
as almost a postdoc
after only two or three years in
graduate school uh getting his phd
he had the imprimatur of great success
and great
uh and great ability in mathematics that
he wouldn't have had as a first year
newbie graduate student so we all we
could never live up to our graduates uh
uh graduate
advisors expectations but yeah go ahead
something i can mention is you know this
idea of turn simon's theory was what we
called it at the time uh
obviously turn and simon's were pure
mathematicians they were doing topology
they were
coming up with different complicated to
me mere mortals
ways of characterizing two and three
dimensional
topologies and so roman shakeev who
thinks of himself as a mathematical
physicist you know he was one of the
people who really
starting in the 1970s uh realized that
you know you could make
physical systems that are in effect
two-dimensional right
sheets of paper or you know sheets of
conductors or something like that
so and and he knew enough about the math
to know that there were things that
could
happen in two-dimensional space that
just can't happen in three-dimensional
space so he borrowed this
math idea from chern and simons and into
a physics idea
and then george and i and roman turned
it into a three plus one dimensional
physics idea
but by there by the time you get there
it's pretty far removed
from what chern and simons actually did
and one of the questions i got at my phd
thesis defense was
do you think if you showed this to jim
simons he would he would recognize
anything that you've
at done time i had to say well honestly
i don't know i'm not i'm not completely
sure but now i know he would recognize
it because of you yeah
well that's true and he always is asking
me you know how has my
uh how's my nobel prize uh prospects
looking and
we'll talk about that because that of
course uh drives some of the
some of the excitement not the nobel
prize but the stakes that are involved
and another person i'm showing now
on the fourth slide i think it is is
james clerk maxwell
now i wonder you know if old james were
alive and able to uh
comprehend what he's seeing here would
he really understand
the first set of equations lays this out
really beautifully you talk about gauge
and lorentz and variance or two
symmetries of maxwell's electrodynamics
that have come to dominate all
fundamental physical theory
and i wonder if he would have recognized
that i mean
as far as i know he still had sort of an
again sorry apologies for
getting back into history but i can't
resist these these great scientists
that we're talking about you you get
into these different extensions of
electromagnetism
but at its heart it's really modifying
this master equation this lagrangian
your equation
five by the addition of this term and
the term has a very special force now
did this
equation six where you add this four
vector did that just come to you out of
the blue i mean
what inspires you to or your colleagues
you and your colleagues
to create such a thing that had never
before been considered
well again yeah so you you want to start
with some idea that in this case
came from pure math came from turn turn
and simon's
and they figured out a way to they
figured out what we now call a
topological invariant
of three manifolds so what that means is
you have some
complicated mathematical thing which is
three dimensional so locally
it has three dimensions there's an up
down left right forward backward
but maybe you can wrap around itself
like there are doughnut holes and you
know boundaries or whatever
and the ongoing program of mathematical
topologists is to say
how do you know if two mathematical
shapes are the same
if you can deform them into each other
and there's no algorithm for answering
that question
right so what you can do instead is say
well here are two
things i can calculate about these
different spaces
that would be the same if they were
deformable into each other so like the
dimensionality of a space is a
topological invariant okay
and and i encourage people to check out
uh i did a series of videos
the biggest ideas in the universe i do a
whole video on geometry and topology
where i talk about this stuff
um but anyway it's their topological
invariant was specific to three
dimensions
it's not meant in fact odd number
dimensions more more generally it's not
meant to work in four dimensions
so our equation six no one else had ever
written down before
even chern and simon's this was our
four-dimensional version
of what something like a churn simon's
term would look like and
the important thing about it if even if
you don't know anything about
lagrangians or
physics at all if you zoom in and see
the very first
thing that appears there after the minus
one half there's a p
alpha and that p alpha represents a
vector
in space time that picks out a preferred
direction
that's why it violates lorenzen variance
because the rensom variant says
there are no preferred directions in
space there are no preferred velocities
etc
this picks out a preferred direction and
that direction is the time
axis correct or the axis is connecting
we assumed it was but you don't have to
assume that we made our lives easy the
paper was long enough and
inspected enough as it was what's so
interesting about this paper is that you
actually
not only propose a new modification to
one of the most if not the most
sacrosanct
uh fundamental theories of nature namely
uh maxwellian electrodynamics
uh but you also subject it to test
observational tests and we're gonna get
into that because obviously the subject
today
is the claimed um extraction of this
very effect
reproducing a type of special rotation
in the cosmic microwave background
polarization axis linear polarization
axis
that i want to discuss but
you you know the thing that really
speaks to me is that you included not
only some
the speculative theory but also the
potentiality for testing it with
existing data that you had access to at
that time
so the um i want to just get briefly
into why these types of
of measurements are hard to do and
actually how we experimental
simple experimentalists go about trying
to measure these things and why
of course one of the main goals in
cosmology is to detect
perhaps the imprint of primordial
gravitational waves
produced by an expansionary period that
we call inflation
and you've worked on this as well and
you've worked on an allied subject
related to
dark energy and accelerating universe uh
but
i wonder you know if we if we comment on
here i'm showing a slide
uh that i borrowed from professor matt
muse uh and um
uh in the cal state system he has this
beautiful diagram with kind of these
blocks that my kids love to put together
well one likes to put it together and
the other one breaks it so it's kind of
the symbiotic
relationship but he he's declaring here
there's a theory of
everything that underpins all of reality
and it is supporting bricks that are
labeled quantum mechanics lorenz
symmetry and
curved spacetime those then feed into
the standard model
of particle physics and general
relativity
and then those support newton's laws
classical dynamics electromagnetism
atoms cosmology classical cosmology
newtonian gravity
but his point is that if you perturb the
system on the next slide
you get something really wacky that if
you break loren symmetry
you actually will have repercussions
downstream namely you'll be able to see
effects
in the atomic world and electromagnetism
cosmology and gravity
uh so the first thing i want to uh get
into that some are asking in the chat
room
what is your feeling about a theory of
everything does such a thing have to
exist i
i've wondered often i've never asked you
this i had a series of webinars over the
summer with
uh eminent physicist lee smallin sabine
hosenfelder eric weinstein
max tag mark lisa randall
and and others um do you think there's a
need do we need a theory of everything
sean
well there is a theory of everything the
universe does something
whatever the universe is doing that's
the theory of everything the question is
can we human beings
find a version of that theory of
everything that we can understand and
that covers all the bases
uh i think probably but i don't know
we'll have to find out
so one argument you know i haven't used
this on you uh
because we haven't spoken since december
when we were actually in person
in the uh travel district of los angeles
international airport
uh that was that was great um and yeah
we did a conversation on uh
on something deeply hidden that was
wonderful you can find a link to it in
my uh
back catalog and we also have links to
your youtube channel
as well and your books but uh one of the
things i've been asking lately is
in what sense do we need we talk about
unifying gravity with quantum mechanics
but
there's no well you don't believe in god
but there's no letter from
you know some deity that says gravity
and quantum mechanics have to be unified
and then i always hear well
at the center of a black hole or at the
big bang there was a singularity and you
can't have a singularity
without you can't understand a
singularity without a quantum theory of
gravity
what if there are no singularities first
of all would we would you still say we
need a theory of quantum gravity
i mean of course we need a theory of
quantum gravity has nothing to do with
singularities or black holes but our
current theory gravity says
if you have some energy or mass right
here
it gives rise to a gravitational field
of the following form
quantum mechanics says i can take that
energy or mass
and put it in a superposition of being
here
and being there okay so that
superposition
causes some kind of gravitational field
what kind of gravitational field does it
cause we need the theory of quantum of
gravity to answer them
and some are asking you to do something
very dangerous
uh dallas here i'll put up his comment
uh he's asking you to comment
on the theories of everything of uh of
uh past guests on the show including
uh stephen wolfram uh eric weinstein
and uh max tegmark uh would you would
you take that challenge can you comment
on
why is there this proliferation but i
don't really agree with uh i encourage
people to check out my podcast
conversation with him on the mindscape
podcast
you know uh it's good to be ambitious
but it's better to be right
so most ambitious ideas including even
observational tests like we're going to
talk about
later are going to be wrong you've got
to be able to deal with that
yeah so i have a guest uh coming up in a
few weeks nema
our connie hamed of the institute for
advanced studies and
he's famous for saying things like you
know it's very hard to break the
standard model i mean it's very hard to
do and i'm depicting
here matt muse is depicting here but
let's talk about that uh more
so first of all with lorentz and
variance i'm just summarizing what you
said earlier
the symmetry under various translations
rotations and boosts
it's implicitly assumed within special
relativity and gr
it's it's basically a foundational
aspect component of
of the standard model of of of
particle physics and beyond and so
therefore breaking it would be
quite revolutionary another thing that
that um
carol jacqui field uh effect would
manifest is in parity violation
can you comment on what is parity
violation who cares if it's uh violated
uh can we can we all just get along with
two hands that don't fit in the same
glove
well parity is violated in particle
physics so it's not that surprising um
and by the way let me mention that even
though lorentz and variance is
absolutely a pillar
of modern physics
one of the reasons why our paper was
popular is because we violate it in a
very benign
innocent way we violate in a way that
doesn't make everything else break it's
still
local quantum field theory you know it's
still obeying the rules that we're all
set up with it just picks out a
preferred reference frame in the
universe which is certainly
interesting but it's not likely to start
from scratch with quantum mechanics and
space time and
all of that um parity is a particular
subset in some sense of grenson variance
which says
you can take a system that has some
shape right some orientation
and you flip its orientation so if you
have a set of vectors
that are perpendicular to each other you
can sort of flip them so the other way
around i can't do it with my hand like i
go left hand there you go it's like it's
there between this and this okay
left-handed and right-handed that is the
actual difference sometimes people say
it's as if you
hold a mirror up to something and
if you think about particle physics
right if you think about two particles
bumping into each other and interacting
and going off their own way
it's the most natural thing in the world
to think that if you
have an interaction that happens with a
certain probability because of the rules
of quantum mechanics
and all you do is ask about the same
interaction but in a mirror
it should have the same probability
should be completely invariant under
that right and so it was big nobel prize
winning stuff
when in the 19 i think the 1960s they
showed that no actually parity is not an
exact symmetry of nature the weak
interactions
of particle physics violate parity
gravity
and the strong interactions and
electromagnetism all
satisfy parity but the weak interactions
violated
isn't it possible though that gravity
could violate it in the sense that
you added a term to the einstein tensor
that's not unlike your term
uh that you would get chiral
gravitational waves that would in theory
you know we could never test it maybe
but uh but some including lee smallin
stephon alexander etcetera
have thought about if there is a theory
of everything all the forces are unified
gravity has to
at some point in the history of the
universe have chirality of parity
violation
what do you make of such conjectures
like that
so you said two things uh one thing is
isn't it possible that and the answer is
always yes
any respectable physicist will always
say yes it's
possible we don't know what the
fundamental theory of everything is like
you said so
sure it's possible but then you said you
know doesn't it have to be
the gravity violates chirality river no
it doesn't have to be
that this is where we should be humble
we just don't know that's why
this kind of exploration is important
because we don't know
ahead of time how these things work we
should hypothesize that maybe they work
and then go look for their experimental
events so let's do a counter factual
godankin experiment to throw a lot of
scrabble words in there
um so imagine that the weak nuclear
force
did obey parity and just somebody told
you that in 1989
you know right you're a bushy-eyed
bright-eyed graduate student
there's no parody violation in nature at
all sean uh would you still write this
paper in other words doesn't does not
the existence of parody violation in the
in the weak sector suggests that there
could as again
possible arise a violation in a lecture
week or
in electromagnetism solo yeah no
absolutely i mean physicists are people
too
and when you think about different
hypothetical scenarios that we haven't
tested yet
uh different people are going to give
different credences
to them some ideas they're going to
think are very reasonable very probable
this is a good thing let's go look
for it other ideas even though they're
also speculative and we're not sure yet
they're going to say
i'm not even going to bother looking for
that so there's no question that you
know we discovered
both the parody was violated uh and then
we discovered the time
reversal symmetry was violated another
nobel prize winning effort
uh so by now we're used to these
symmetries breaking just a little bit
and you know like i said uh lorenz
invariants and these sort of
orientation flipping symmetries are not
even as fundamental as gauge invariance
is so maybe we shouldn't be surprised if
these symmetries are broken at a
fundamental level i mean i
i'm absolutely a big believer that
quantum gravity
might very well give rise to violations
of lorenzen variants
other people have investigated this idea
um but it's one of the very very few
handles
experimentally that we might have on
quantum gravity so we should take that
super duper seriously
and then of the three discrete there are
three discrete symmetries in which you
can invert
uh a parameter a binary parameter plus
and minus
and charge and and parity left to right
and then in time uh is there an analog
of this carol effect
etc in terms of time reversal
symmetry being violated as the sub as a
subclass
of lorenz and variance violation
well like you say there's these three
symmetries there's parody which is the
mirror time
reversal forward and backward in time
and there's charge conjugation
which basically takes matter and
anti-matter and
flips them into each other so we've
detected violations of
p and c and c p and t you know all these
different things but the combination
cpt where you take an experiment
hold up at the mirror run it backward in
time
and flip all the particles to
anti-particles
that seems to be like a good symmetry of
nature
in fact there's a theorem the cpt
theorem
which says that under very general
assumptions cpt
has to be a symmetry of nature true
confession
time we didn't even realize when we
wrote this paper in 1990 that our theory
violates cpt
which it does and the reason so you know
once you
this is an example of the diagrams you
showed once you break something a little
bit
there are downstream effects of other
people other things breaking that
depended on what you started with
uh so uh mark gehaldia
i think i'm mangling that name max to
maximum extent
uh he or she is asking uh wouldn't the
many worlds
uh interpretation be a theory of
everything
it's a different kind of thing because
we have a technical definition of what
we mean by
a theory of everything it's a theory of
everything is not just a theory of the
whole universe
it's a complete theory of the whole
universe at the fundamental microscopic
level so something like the many worlds
formulation of quantum mechanics
is a paradigm it's a way of saying this
is how quantum mechanics works
but it's not a specific theory right uh
quantum electromagnetism the standard
model of particle physics
you know a qubit in a in a quantum
computer or something like that
these are specific physical models
all of them can be described within
the many worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics when physicists say
that we're looking for a theory of
everything we want the specific model
that describes the actual world down
deep into its bones and maybe or maybe
not that'll be part of
the many worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics so
i want to turn back to our slides now
there's a picture of jim simons for
those of you playing at home
let me get that up here so this is uh
the term that you added that we spoke
about earlier so
you've already nicely described how that
is added
i want to point out that this is not the
first time that such a claim has been
made
even in the context of cmb results we're
going to talk about an earlier violation
detection
claim in the late 1990s which got me
extremely excited as a graduate student
that you actually played a role in
debunking and i want to get to
why i believe that shows almost a heroic
level of scientific integrity
uh i've spoken on eric weinstein's
podcast about you specifically
being illustrative of the way a good
scientist works his or her best to of uh
to avoid confirmation bias and how some
of the great scientists in history from
galileo to einstein fell victim to it so
i always say it's too bad they could
have had good careers but
um but i want to take us back to august
2009 when
a claim was made of a three sigma
detection
of cpt violation using a chern simon's
like violation the exact same term that
you included
in 1990 so this was by
gia uh lee and zhang uh they're all
friends of mine
and they were basically analyzing data
from the bicep
w map and uh and boomerang uh cmb
polarimeters and using those data to
construct a very high conf or relatively
high confidence
several sigma detection three sigma
which is higher than the current
uh paper under discussion that we're
talking about
and as i always joke one of my late
colleagues used to say you know at three
sigma
you can come and give a seminar you know
at five sigma
you know they'll they'll pay for the
seminar and at you know seven sigma you
can go to stockholm
uh but you know sometimes those go away
too by the way but
uh but looking at this paper this really
set me off on a campaign with one of my
graduate students john kaufman
who is now a phd out in boston area
and we started looking at cosmic
birefringence of the carol variety
and how to be manifest so the next slide
shows cosmic birefringence
with basically what does it mean to
exhibit this effect
assume nature has this added term in
electromagnetic lagrangian
you add a turn simon's term it would
mean that the vacuum
is birefringent it would mean that a
photon of the left circular polarization
state
would travel slower or faster depending
on the sign of this effect and the
coupling
it would travel slower or faster such
that when traversing cosmic distances
the a rotation would accrue and a
measurable rotation
the signature polarization and this is
how your polarized sunglasses work
is that for every one physical rotation
of the polarizer my
face will get darker and brighter for
some this is great fun when i'm fully
extinguished
it'll get extinguished twice per
physical rotation
and this is relying on the fact that
when you extinguish
one when you select one polarization
state and then you uh measure an
orthogonal state you have zero photons
transmitted
and so what we do with our cmv
polarimeters is we build detectors that
are
intrinsically sensitive to one
polarization state or the other
and we essentially do this modulation
where we rotate the polarizers with
respect to one another
in order to see if the incoming light is
polarized and if so how
now what the universe would exhibit uh
if there were such a by
a cp you know this lorentz and parity
violating property
is that an initially polarized vertical
photon would rotate and become slightly
horizontal or rotated with respect to
its original
uh orientation state that's how you
would detect it and it was claimed as i
said back in uh
in 2009 based on bicep 1 data so the
original bicep data
half the subject of my book revolves
around bicep 1 the other half sort of
bicep2
and and why the stakes are so high when
we do polarimetry
and now i'm showing a cover of the new
york times this is from
april uh 18th 1997
and i'll show it on the screen here here
we go and
it's a cover and it shows uh what i
always think is interesting is that the
new york times is
time translation invariant as well so
some of the same people
that were on the headlines in 1997 uh
including a newt gingrich up here and
benjamin netanyahu over here they're
still in the news
and pataki sometimes hear about him uh
anyway it's interesting but that's not
what i want to draw your attention to
down here it's a it's a sub head it's on
the front page of the new york times it
says this side up
may apply to the universe after all so i
know that i remember where i was when i
first saw this
paper and uh i want to get shawn to take
us back
to 1997. there's essentially a claim
made using the properties of radio
galaxies which are distant astronomical
objects known to have certain
polarization properties
you are um a freshly minted phd or
you're a postdoc
or maybe you're a professor at chicago
yeah so you're at the itp
um and you are coming across this
this paper which basically seems to have
detected the very effect
that you now they don't cite your paper
in the book and they the
in the new york times but it's
effectively a detection of what you
predicted
how did you feel as a person tell me
what that felt like that satisfaction
that you might have had must have had
tell us what it felt like and then as a
physicist and what happened
next so this is um
you know part of what i did that
original 1990 paper was
what we were doing was looking at radio
galaxies so radio galaxies often have
these long
elongated jets right there's a black
hole at the center spewing off matter in
some direction
and what happens is if the matter gets
spewed off it stretches magnetic fields
along with it and so these magnetic
fields you know where they're aligned
they're aligned along the jet that's
you can test this experimentally but
it's the most obvious
guess also and what that means is that
electrons
swirl around perpendicular to the
magnetic field
they give off radiation the radio
telescopes can detect so if you know
what a radio galaxy is and does
you predict with very very high
confidence that the polarization of
light
from the radio galaxy will be
perpendicular to the jet because that's
what the electrons are doing they're
moving around perpendicular to where the
jet is
and so what what george basically
realized george field was that you know
if you collected a bunch of radio
galaxies with redshifts
and polarizations and you and you what
we call the position angle the
where exactly the jet was on the sky uh
an eager young graduate student could
type all that in
this by the way was the days when you
had to like photocopy papers and then
type in the data
okay so that was me uh and then make
plots
of whether or not it was true that in
fact the polarization was perpendicular
to the jet
and if we had this birefringence effect
it would all be
rotated a little bit and it would be
rotated more the further
apart the further away from us you were
so we looked for that and we found no
there was no observable effect we put an
upper limit there was not very much
rotation if any in the polarization and
then yes seven years later the front
page of the new york times says someone
has discovered it
look to be honest my immediate response
was that's wrong
there was no time i did not get any
moment of satisfaction
uh where i said oh my goodness they
found something and
i'll tell you the reason why it's
because in the new york times article
they mentioned that the researchers used
160 radio galaxies
and i remembered i typed in 160 radio
galaxies so
they weren't using different data or
better data than me they were using the
data that i had typed in
i didn't collect any of it that was
collected by real astronomers not me
but i knew that our data had any
observable effect in it so i knew that
they were wrong
and i'll tell you why they're wrong and
i feel like you know dancing on the
grave a little bit because they were so
wrong
it's kind of it's kind of funny almost
for some reason
they thought that the polarization of
the
of the radiation should be parallel to
the radio galaxy
not perpendicular to it and so the
problem with that is of course
polarization
is only defined plus or minus 180
degrees
because the electric field goes up and
down right so it's not like it's defined
this way or that way right
180 degrees gives you the same answer
right right
so what how do you know if what the
polarization is
you have to resolve it somehow and what
they did was they said well in one half
of the sky we'll assume the angle is
between 0 and 180
and in the other half of the sky we'll
assume it's between
0 and minus 180. now you and i know that
it's actually 90
all the time so what they found was that
in one half of the sky it was
rotated by 90 degrees and the other half
of the sky is rotated the other way
by 90 degrees but that's the same
rotation it's not any different
so they just made a conceptual error it
was not like they made a
an analysis mistake or anything like
that so george and i
actually george emailed me and he said
like you should look at the new york
times and i said yeah yeah
and then he emailed me again he said no
no you really really should look at it
and i did and
literally over the weekend uh you know
we wrote a paper saying here's why it's
wrong
yeah well you have a lot more uh control
self-control stoicism than i do
yeah i always thought when you after you
explained it so i'm showing your paper
from 1997
with the histogram distribution under
the slide that says radio galaxy
polarization
it was kind of like you know remember
when you used to play chicken
in high school sean and you'd say like
you go right
and i'll go left you know that usually
doesn't work out so well so anybody who
plays chicken
make sure not to heed that particular
convention
but again since uh this is one of my
undergraduates kelsey lund put this
slide together the next uh the next
view graph has a uh display
of of the number of publications
uh mentioning cosmic birefringence it
starts with a lonely peak
at 1990 and that's sean's famous paper
and then it builds as a slow you know i
wish my stock portfolio looked like this
and it's really just gone up almost
exponentially and the reason is i think
the stakes in some sense couldn't be
higher
i was joking you know earlier if if god
in my case gave me a piece of paper and
said on this piece of paper write down
which do you want to detect
primordial b modes from inflation or
lorentz invariant cosmic birefringence
and chern simon's type i would
definitely choose the latter because i
think
many people assume that the former took
place and it's almost a foregone
conclusion that something like inflation
if not inflation itself took place i
mean i don't want to i don't know how
much you want to get into yeah but
um part of this resurgence was
many of the astronomy buffs out there
will recognize
1997 as the year before 1998.
and in 1998 uh people discovered that
the universe is accelerating due to
something which we call
dark energy and you know sometimes good
things come out of
mistakes and so even though i think that
the nonlinear also paper was a mistake
it got me thinking
again about cosmic by refrigerants and
things like that
and in 1998 i realized that rather than
violating the rent's invariance with
some vector that we just
made up you could ask you know is there
an effect that dark energy could have
on the polarization of uh
background photons and it's the same
effect and so i wrote a paper explaining
that if dark energy exists and is
dynamical is quintessence
you should expect to see some
cosmological birefringence and to my
mind
that's a way better motivation than
violating the renson variant
yeah i think that's uh your quintessence
in the rest of the world paper is that
is that it right yeah
so um moving on there were many other
detections that have come about since
the measurements of non-zero rotation
angle but most of those we attribute in
this paper with john kaufman
that i've linked here this is basically
the
misapplication of the way that
systematic errors propagate from
experiment to experiment
and really the lack there uh there of of
an astronomical reference source
for astronomical calibration of
polarization angle
the reason it's so hard and you and i
have talked about this before uh a
rotation of your detector by a minuscule
amount
can introduce the same type of effect
that would masquerade
as a real rotation of the cmb photons uh
polarization state leaving you to
misattribute a detection
of cosmic birefringence and so we we
work to great
lengths to reduce this type of
systematic error
the problem is the way to reduce a
systematic error this is for the real
cognizante the birefringence and
systematics
you can skip over that but that a small
rotation of your axis can be
detrimental and it could be much larger
and induce a signal far far
larger than the cosmic signals that are
sought and so we started thinking about
well how could you
calibrate your instrument's polarization
angle and it turns out
whereas for most uh astronomical sources
even in the cmb measurement what the
planck instrument did
for for its temperature calibration or
the wmap
uh satellites beach ball behind me is
that they use say jupiter and jupiter is
a known black body
it has a known size and distance to the
earth etc
and therefore it's a very reliable
absolute temperature calibration
standard but there is no what i call
standard stick there's no
object that we know exactly what its
orientation is and so
we cannot absolutely calibrate our
polarization angles
using this with the cmb as easily as we
can
calibrate the temperature response so we
go to great links to do this
and some of them different ways are
shown here but again none of these are
as
standard a candle as is the uh
measurement of cmb temperature and
isotropy so it's a great challenge to us
but again the stakes are quite high
we've actually gone so far as to propose
uh building
a satellite a brad johnson at the
university of virginia has proposed a
satellite
that would orbit the earth not looking
out at the cmb but looking down at the
earth
spraying it with a conversation with a
calibration signal that we would use
to measure our polarization angles
against
so before we turn back to the paper and
and maybe just uh finish up with the
most recent plank analysis
and what's what's come of it i want to
point out there are many
experiments that are seeking to measure
the
cosmic microwave backgrounds
polarization in particular looking for
uh effect due to primordial
perturbations whether they be
gravitational waves or even density
perturbations
and using it as a probe of all the
physics in the intervening universe and
perhaps
earlier prior to the uh the apocalyptic
coupling
but some of them are shown here i think
i got a fairly exhaustive list
but the um the the comments i asked
ichiro kamatsu and
uh to come on this podcast with us uh
but he wanted to wait
until some of these uh experiments
return data
i didn't have the heart to break it to
him that you know many of these are not
observing
and won't be observing for many years
due to that maybe he did
but um but let's get back to the
original uh the original
claim which is that this this effect of
this causing fire refringence effect
was measured with this extremely high uh
level of confidence 99.2
confidence what does that mean when you
when you hear such a number
how should we think about the
interpretation i mean if i had a 99.2
percent chance of dying in a plane crash
the next
commercial airline i took i would not
get on that plane uh
what what do you think about this uh
this type of uh confidence level
how do you be very uh clear just so no
one misunderstands
i think this result is probably going to
go away i think it's probably wrong if i
were to bet right now
despite them saying it's a 0.2 of it
going away
right and that's because you know that
this confidence level 99.8 or whatever
it is
doesn't mean there's a 99.8 chance this
is right
what it means is that if you did
something like this
over and over again many many times you
should not get a signal this
large except for 0.2 of the time
okay so the signals should be smaller
but that fact
uh hides a number of other facts number
one you're looking for lots of different
things
right so you're actually doing a lot of
different things you're going to get
unlikely things
someone wins the lottery even though
it's unlikely that you're going to win
the lottery
number two you get more excited when you
see a result than when you just see what
exactly what you expected so you're more
likely to write a paper about it
uh number three as you've already
indicated there are
systematic effects so there are effects
that are
not exactly uh random numbers
that there can be hidden effects that
push all of your errors in the same
direction
and that can trick you into into seeing
something uh and number four
most importantly this would be such a
big deal
that you should be super duper cautious
about it no matter what okay
so i think that it's very interesting
very intriguing that they claim that
there's some evidence here
the confidence level even at 98 99.8
you want it to be way higher than that
just as a numerical fact
and also you want it to be verified by
independent groups not just by one
telescope because any one telescope can
have a
secret little mistake in it uh so it's
not something that's going to be cleared
up in the next couple weeks
and so uh that's yeah that's very uh
that's very good to hear
that take from you we have a question
from stuart volkow who's the
producer of the into the impossible
podcast he's taking
advantage of his proximity to me uh
stewart's asking what is shawn looking
forward to that may come out of
observations from the next generation
instruments coming online like beer
ruben observatory
obviously simon's observatory are there
uh other probes that could get at this
effect uh you mentioned 130 radio
galaxies back in 1990
well how many are there now are there
other ways to get out cosmic
birefringence besides the cmb
yeah well in fact the cmb was not even
something we thought of if you think
about 1990
it's hard you know some of your viewers
i'm sure we're not born yeah
like 90s it's pre-coping that makes me
very sad but it's probably true
um we hadn't discovered the anisotropies
in the cosmic microwave background in
1990. we knew
that they were there and we knew that we
had uh satellites in the sky that we're
gonna look for them and hopefully find
them but
we hadn't i mean the whole thing had
been under theorized in some sense you
know
um i'm sure jim peoples knew all of it
but the community as a whole was was not
nearly as informed about the
meaningfulness
of cmv and isotropics as they as they
could have been
and so when george and roman and i did
it we use radio galaxies and that was
more than good enough to show that the
effect is going to be small if it's
there at all when i wrote my paper about
quintessence
there you know unlike the my paper was
george and roman where we just made
something up
you know no good reason for it to be
there uh you can make up whatever
size effect you want and we put an upper
limit on it
with the quintessence stuff there is a
target
there's a natural size for that effect
to be
and i was tickled to see it was
smaller than the current limits but big
enough to potentially be observable
that's why i got very excited about that
particular effect um but
these days you know we do as you say
look at the cmb
to do it um people soon figured out that
was a
something you could do it's a more
subtle analysis because you have to
you know there's not like it's not like
a radio galaxy which does look like a
stick in the sky
right you know the cmb is is a more
complicated beast
um but also you know if you want to know
what else i'm interested in
we all know there is something called
the hubble tension
um there's this purported disagreement
between cosmological parameters as
measured by the cmb with the planck
satellite wmap etc
and the expansion rate of the universe
has measured in our local neighborhood
the hubble constant okay
one of the possible explanations that
this tension between these different
measurements is tricky because
unlike the acceleration of the universe
that we discovered in 1998
there's no obvious explanation there's
no obvious theory
that would easily fit this particular
discrepancy
so you kind of have to bend over
backwards a little bit and you
worry about it the the joke that
theorists say is that it's an
experimental result that has not yet
been confirmed by theory
and and i think i think who who said
um eddington said never believe in
experiment until it's confirmed by
theory
there you go so but nevertheless there
are theories people
people write down theories uh you know
my my friend and colleague uh
mark kaminkowski had a theory one of
many theories
to propose to get rid of the hubble
tension which is
dark energy but not now an
early period of dark energy before
recombination before the microwave
background was formed
and that could also be a kind of dark
energy that gives rise to birefringence
in the cosmic microwave background
so even if we see the the by repressions
there it's not necessarily the
quintessence that i was talking about it
could be something more exotic
and so i don't have a target to shoot
for in
future experiments so much as i have a
bigger smorgasbord
of things i want to understand better
parody violation uh tensor modes
with gravitational waves reconciling the
hubble tension all these things
are potential discovery vectors and so
we need to push forward on all of that
yeah that brings up you know kind of an
allied point from an experimentalist
point of view
uh in addition to the many flowers that
will hopefully bloom
when we go to measure the primordial
beam modes we get limits
on this type of birefringence for free
we get limits on things like axions
which i want to conclude our
conversation just getting your take on
that
but the other thing that we get that we
know exists is are called primordial
magnetic fields
in other words we know the primordial
that we know that magnetic fields exist
in all bound
clusters of objects there's a cluster
that's uh
10 megaparsecs across it has a magnetic
field that's been measured
but we don't have yet a measurement at
truly cosmological distances that are
not
gravitationally collapsed and so the
theory is that some
early time in the universe there could
have been a seed field perhaps a relic
of a phase transition
et cetera but we have a lower limit uh
and we have upper limits and so what we
try to do as experimentalists is
converge the upper limit to the lower
limit
and hopefully result in a detection and
so that i see is a low risk i see
looking for you know if you were just
building an experiment and your
and your proposal was to look for
causing birefringence only
that probably shouldn't be funded but if
you can get all this other
cool stuff the primordial perturbations
from inflation perimeter magnetic fields
limits on evolution of dark energy
etc uh i think it's it's it becomes
uh very fruitful to pursue such things
where you have guaranteed results in
some sense
similar with neutrino masses and one of
the comments is a question about dark
matter which i always say
neutrinos are the only form of dark
matter we know exists
that have mass and actually uh don't
interact other than
weekly and gravitationally so a person
by the name of outsmoked
is asking hi sean i wonder why isn't
dark matter mentioned in the formation
of supermassive black holes
uh if we know that dark matter warped
space bend space
wouldn't it end up in a black hole in
the end so does dark matter with dark
matter be
be part of a black hole
well it might very well have something
to do with it but there's a good reason
why we think that ordinary matter
even though there's much less ordinary
matter than dark matter
uh is has an easier time forming black
holes
than dark matter does namely that
ordinary matter can stick together
so you get a bunch of ordinary matter
hydrogen atoms or whatever and they run
into each other and they stick you make
a shock wave or a pancake or a bunch of
stars or a black hole or whatever
because ordinary matter dissipates it
gives off light
and heat it interacts
electromagnetically and so there's all
these extra forces over and above
gravity that allow ordinary matter
to condense into very dense objects and
eventually form black holes
whereas dark matter as we know this from
the bullet cluster and other
observations
you send two clouds of dark matter
together they just go right through each
other
so there might be a lot of mass in them
but it's not high density
mass to squeeze the dark matter into a
really tiny
uh region of space is really really hard
it just tends to go right through your
fingers
and another candidate for uh for the
dark matter and some extent is the axion
i wonder can you say something about
axions that was coined term coined by
frank wilcek who's an upcoming guest on
the podcast
uh and for his new book coming out early
next year
uh i wonder can you say something about
that and and how is it an allied or is
it an allied uh phenomenon
uh related to the carol field and
jacquie method mechanism
yeah the axion is a very promising dark
matter candidate
uh it's becoming more and more promising
every day not because of anything that
axions are doing but because their
biggest competitor
are something called weakly interacting
massive particles which we put a lot of
effort into detecting
and haven't detected yet okay we could
have detected
weakly interacting massive particles yet
we haven't
we haven't yet crossed the threshold
where we've ruled them out by any means
but every time we could have detected it
and we don't their probability goes down
and the probability of everything else
goes up a little bit right so the axions
are more popular now than it used to be
and like the quintessence that we talked
about the stuff that gives rise to
birefringence
the axiom is what we call a pseudoscaler
field
if you do this parity transformation
take the axion and hold it up to a
mirror
it turns into opposite of what it was in
some in some well
in some sense it's going to remain vague
for this discussion but it's actually
mathematically very well defined
and what that means is axions interact
with electromagnetism in exactly the
same way
as this quintessence field would
interact the difference is the
quintessence field
very very slowly rolls down its
potential so that over cosmological time
a photon builds up a polarization
rotation that eventually we can
observe whereas an axion very rapidly
oscillates back and forth so there's no
net effect whatsoever
on the polarization there's
particle physics effects you can try to
actually shoot a magnetic field or a
photo
shoot a photon through a magnetic field
and have it turn into an axion
or vice versa turn on a magnetic field
let axons go through it and look for
photons being produced
um but so it's a family cousin but not
exactly the same effect very good
uh i can't uh resist just asking you
your thoughts on the recent
awarding of the nobel prize to uh sir
roger penrose to andre
guess and to reinhard genzel what did
you
make of it how do you react to it it's
sort of a unique prize in a sense
uh going especially the component that
went to sir roger
and then the observation and notice it
didn't say for a black hole discovery
did it so what was your reaction to that
to that nobel prize i mean i think it's
good
nobel prize because it's good science
that is being rewarded i
i don't really follow carefully enough
what exactly the citation was
or so forth but we've all seen these
movies that they made of stars
zipping around to some very massive very
dark object at the center of our galaxy
um and i think this is one of those
things that crept up on us
right you know black holes have been
understood
since the sixties uh we've had some
evidence for them
since the seventies the evidence got a
lot better
when uh uh gays and genzel did their uh
observations near the center of the
galaxy
the evidence got even better when ligo
found gravitational waves from black
holes but ligo already won the nobel
prize okay so that's in there
so i think what happened was you know
there was sort of a it wasn't like a
big phase transition so much as a
gradual creeping up to the point where
people said well
we have enough evidence to say that yes
black holes really exist and here are
these people who have observed them
they win the nobel prize and then
someone in the back of the room can say
something like well
that's the experiment what about the
theoretical side of things
and someone says well i guess you know
probably the best work theoretically on
black holes was hawking in penrose back
in the 1960s and hawking is no longer
with us
penrose still is uh so that's a very
deserving nobel prize although i was
surprised that he got it i would not
have picked that yeah
it was uh it was interesting i mean i
think he's he's done a lot he also has
his own alternative cosmological models
which are
nothing short of controversial uh but uh
but yeah it was certainly gratifying to
see
uh the recognition of this wonderful of
this wonderful award and and
uh and just the excitement that it
brings to astronomy winning
racking up all this attention and
accolades um
well sean uh we've come to the end of
the of the hour i want to uh thank you
so much
uh and also refer people to uh to your
youtube channel
which uh is easily accessed or your
preposterous universe blog
your many books one of which has been
shown this whole time something deeply
hidden
a phenomenal book i have an interview
with sean about that from back in
december 2019
bc before covet and uh and i want to
thank you for everything you do
uh both personally that you have helped
me the way that you
provide a role model for for physicists
and how to react and act with integrity
as a scientist
your outreach your communication skills
and uh your
your your ability to eat almost any type
of hot sauce no matter what the scoville
rating
never been invited on the hot ones you
know that's a future goal for me
i'll see what i can do all right sean be
well
say hi to jennifer for us and uh we wish
you the best and hopefully we'll have
you back
when these results are confirmed if not
sooner i'll be too important i won't
come on your podcast anymore
at hot sauce
thank you very much bye everybody thank
you so much for joining us on the into
the impossible podcast the special
uh sean carroll edition you can find a
few different things i've done with sean
in the past find his blog
find him on twitter and uh and you won't
be disappointed uh
and uh especially uh thanks to
to uh the producer of the show stewart
volkow for helping arrange it
and putting it together that's all for
now stay tuned for more upcoming
interesting exciting
analysis and news and interviews in the
coming weeks with as i said
frank wilcheck barry barish and many
other scientists
uh and i do want to put a plug out for a
live stream i'm going to be doing with
adam reese
wendy friedman john 11 and
uh and i'm forgetting who else is oh
professor sarah seeger
of the uh of uh mit we're doing a live
stream to commemorate the 100th
anniversary
of the great debates in astronomy which
took place in
the famous curtis shapley debate that
the that
live stream will be on the evening of
november 10th
and we will do it uh in conjunction with
the wyoming star gazing association
which is an organization that i'm
involved with that has access to half
meter diameter size telescopes
will be reviewing some of the hubble
space telescope's greatest hits
because it's also the hubble telescope's
30th anniversary 30th birthday
these are just incredible uh milestones
to reach
both in our understanding of the size
the scale the scope of our universe
in the case of the curtis shapley debate
and also
in the context of the hubble telescope
celebrating its anniversary so who
better to share it with
than a bunch of friends looking at
telescopes live
on the air in the evening of a november
10th so stay tuned please subscribe to
this channel
and subscribe to the podcast version the
into the impossible podcast on apple
itunes or google
play please leave ratings and so forth
that's how we get
more attention so we can get great
guests like sean on such short notice
as really such a treat and the many many
luminous intellects that we've had on uh
just this past week we had emily
levesque
professor of uh of astronomy at the
university of washington
and in the next couple of weeks we're
gonna have this stellar outstanding cast
of characters
uh so please do subscribe to the into
the impossible
podcast to this youtube channel leave a
like leave a notification
i don't know if you can leave a
notification anyway this has been a
blast for me thanks to sean thanks to
all of you out there for your awesome
questions
and uh please subscribe to my newsletter
so you'll get uh be the first to know
whenever i do a live stream like this
signing off i am your fearful host in
this time of pandemic podcast
professor brian keating university of
california san diego have an
awesome weekend everybody